nous sommes avec olivier blond président
de l'association respire bonjour olivier
blond merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france cet après midi on entendait à
l'instant notre reporter lit la femme
ouzou un qui est actuellement à rouen à
parler de réel traumatisme pour les
riverains à rouen vous vous comprenez le
traumatisme qu'ont vécu ces gens là très
clairement il ya eu une véritable marée
noire qui s'est répandue dans la ville
cesser ces gigantesques dix mille tonnes
d'hydrocarbures qui partent en fumée
c'est c'est vraiment un évidemment un
traumatisme et le deuxième traumatisme
c'est ces îles et sanitaires on sait
bien qu'il va y avoir des conséquences
est la question c'est de justement les
mesures et un an après on a toujours
cette inquiétude sans réponse sur quels
sont les risques auxquels ont été
exposés la population quels sont les
produits chimiques qu'ils ont respiré ou
qu'ils ont été confrontés et c'est très
très très inquiétant alors un an après
cette catastrophe les conclusions des
experts sont toujours inconnues est ce
que la tente ne commence pas être un peu
longue
je sais pas entendu je vous disais que
ça faisait un an donc que ce drame a eu
lieu
les conclusions des experts sont
toujours attendus est ce que la tante
commence à être un peu longue
oui c'est c'est c'est absurde comme
situation on est normalement dans un
état de droit avec des experts avec des
procédures il ya eu plusieurs
commissions une commission denquête une
commune un l'ensemble des
analyses et on ne sait toujours pas ni
comment le la comment surtout c'est
vraiment le plus important
quels sont les risques sanitaires
auxquels la population est exposée
l'association roue on respire que donc
je préside a lancé une étude sanitaire
citoyenne pour essayer d'obtenir des
réponses parce qu'on ne peut pas
attendre des années des années comme ça
mais c'est vraiment le le point noir
cette incertitude que chaque rouennais
chaque habitant de l'agglomération
ressent sur justement qu'est ce qu'ils
risquent qu'est-ce qu'il a risqué à quoi
sont confrontés ses enfants et c'est
inacceptable alors dans notre sujet tout
à l'heure un on a vu les avocats des
victimes de cet incendie
ils annoncent qu'ils vont attaquer
l'état en justice j'imagine que pour
vous c'est une bonne nouvelle
oui oui c'est une bonne nouvelle et en
même temps c'est quelque chose que nous
on a déjà fait en fait on a commencé
quelques jours après l incendie part
justement lancé un référé pour obtenir
déjà des informations et on a mené à son
d'action aussi contre la reprise de
l'activité de l'usiné
ce qui est malheureux c'est qu'on soit
obligés d'aller en justice pour obtenir
satisfaction parce qu'en fait on on
essaie toutes les autres voies et ça ne
marche pas et c'est vrai que la question
de l'accès à l'information est
absolument essentiel il ya toujours
ensemble nos documents qu'ont demandé
qu'on n'a pas il ya des décisions qui
ont été prises dans des institutions par
exemple le coderst alors c'est un
organisme régional d'évaluation des
risques techniques et c'est qui a pris
des décisions sur la base de documents
secrets nous quand on est allé justement
dans les tribunaux il ya des décisions
qui ont été prises sur la base de
documents secrets qu'ils ne nous ont
même pas été communiqué dans le cadre de
la procédure et c'est choquant et donc
le besoin de transparence le besoin de
vérité c'est un besoin qui est commun je
pense à tous les habitants et à toutes
les victimes
alors vous et puis d'autres associations
deux victimes on imagine que vous battez
1 depuis un an pour pour connaître enfin
la vérité
quels ont été les réponses qu'on vous a
donné jusqu'aujourd'hui a encore une
fois sur les risques sanitaires on n'a
aucune réponse rien enfin si ce n'est le
circulez ya rien à voir
rassurez vous vous ne courait aucun
risque est évidemment c'est une réponse
qui est inacceptable
donc tout l'enjeu c'est d'arriver à
trouver des réponses
vous l'avez sans doute vu il ya quelques
années quelques jours par dont plusieurs
ministres sont venus à rouen pour
annoncer ensemble de mesures pour pour
discuter de la praye parce que c'est
aussi ça l'enjeu de c'est aussi ça les
questions c'est la région rouennaise et
très industrielle il ya de nombreux
autres sites seveso
la question c'est aussi comment est ce
qu'on peut faire pour éviter qu'un
nouveau lubrizol ait lieu dans la région
le gouvernement apporte et certaines
réponses les associations pour apporte
certaines propositions les collectivités
aussi je pense qu'il faudrait un grand
dans deux réunions citoyennes pour
discuter tous ensemble de justement de
en fait comment faire pour se protéger à
l'avenir ce que c'est aussi une grande
question
merci beaucoup olivier blanc d'avoir été
avec nous cet après midi sur rt frange
rappelle que vous êtes un président de
l'association rouen respire merci
beaucoup